[Music]
thank you everyone for coming my name is
Preston Holmes I'm part of our IRT
solutions team and today I'm going to be
talking to you sort of about a
cornucopia of a variety of sort of
performance related thoughts that can go
into your IOT solutions so from the very
beginning speed has been part of
Google's philosophy and this was sort of
published in ten things we know ten
things we know to be true many years ago
and in fact back in 2009 we even began
running a number of experiments of about
how does how does speed affect the way
people use Google so we would actually
inject intentional slowness into Google
search to just a very no random
percentage of users and measure how much
were they still interacting with Google
how many searches were they doing we
noticed just introducing you know one to
four hundred milliseconds of delay in
Google search decreased up to a half a
percent how many searches people did and
this idea of very small amounts of
performance impacting the way people
interact with technology also applies to
ecommerce so large e-commerce place did
some research and found that for every
100 milliseconds of latency added to
their experience it actually reduced
sales by 1%
so speed definitely matters but what is
speed when we say fast it can be an
extremely relative concept right so when
we say something needs to be fast what
do we mean speed is measured through
time ranges from nanoseconds to things
like weeks months and years so we have
to think about the context of time and
speed when we talk about performance so
if we look at the very lowest scale less
than a nanosecond what are things that
happen less than a nanosecond well it's
the delay the time between each clock
cycle of like a 3 gigahertz CPU or when
you think about the RF frequency in the
vibration of crystals emitting signals
for things like Wi-Fi less than a
nanosecond per per frequency vibration
and compared to something like a
microcontroller which you might find in
IOT device much slower so we have one
hundred and twenty-five nanoseconds
between each sort of rhythmic clock
cycle on something like a eight
megahertz microcontroller as we go up
now talking about something around
twenty milliseconds when you talk about
controlling things like servos or
dimming lights you have what's called
pulse width modulation this is when you
change the duration of a signal out on a
on one of your i/o pins and these
typically are about twenty milliseconds
in duration these pulses going to fifty
milliseconds this is about the latency
you're gonna find on the network to
reach kind of your nearest Google Cloud
region over all right it can be a little
less it can be a little more but if
you're talking about sort of within your
region it could be around fifty
milliseconds at the just a link side of
that timing it's also about the time it
takes for somebody tapping your big toe
to get to your brain so nerves we think
of nerves and and sensation is being
very fast but our nerves are actually
not that as sort of fast as we think
they are
um this is also about the time you start
to perceive if you're watching a video
when somebody's lip sync if the audio
drifts from the picture is about fifty
milliseconds now if we go to a farther
cloud region if we're going sort of say
halfway around the world or something
like that on a good connection it can be
250 milliseconds so you can see that
these this time scale is sort of in our
in our long distance networking
timeframe it's also about the time it
takes to blink an eye so we also talked
about like in a blink of an eye as being
something very fast but this is now
something we consider rather slow from
from a networking point of view so we
get into the kind of next door of
magnitude here big query while it's very
very good at very fast comp you know
queries across very large datasets
it does take one to three seconds to to
sort of plan a query in bigquery for
those of you that live near the ocean
there's something called slack tide
which is sort of this delay as the tide
sloshes in and then out that's called
slack tide that lasts about an hour and
finally out to a month is something that
you might see it takes about a month for
a strawberry to go from flower to fruit
so if you're a strawberry farmer
trying to optimize operations you
probably aren't carrying about ten
nanoseconds of time in the way the
strawberry grows so every scale of time
has a different impact on performance
performance is also greatly impacted by
many layers in your stack so everything
from the physics of the equipment you're
using up to the application layer so
down at the physics layer this might be
something like the thermal capacitance
of a temperature sensor if you're
looking for you know 100 millisecond
latency on variation of temperature the
truth is the temperature sensor itself
has thermal capacitance and you can't
heat it up or cool it down that fast it
has its own inertia so the physics can't
give you that kind of time resolution of
temperature on the device you're going
to deal not only with things like the
processor speed but also if you're using
any sort of analog to digital converter
we'll talk about the performance of
those systems you've got to send this
information over a potential variety of
local and long ranging communications
protocols each of those can affect the
performance everything you do with the
data and ingesting it and processing it
on the cloud side is obviously going to
have some impact and finally there's a
set of things around the way you can
develop your applications in the way
performance is perceived and that gets
into more about how we as humans can
sort of be fooled into performance and
we'll talk a little bit about each of
these but before we go into them we need
to little we need to know a little bit
more about how we measure and
communicate when we talk about
performance we're going to use this
analogy of moving water from one place
to another and there are really three
terms and three concepts that are used
when when measuring performance and that
is operations latency and throughput so
operations is essentially how many times
can I do this task you know say in an
hour the latency is how long does it
take me to carry one bucket from point A
to point B and throughput often ends up
being sort of a bit of a combination of
the two which is at the end of the hour
how many gallons of water have I moved
now there's more than one way to achieve
throughput so you can take three smaller
buckets and move them in series one
after another very quickly with very low
latency or you can move one
larger bucket more slowly and it results
in the same throughput you can move
three buckets concurrently and again
same latency in this situation and same
throughput or you can combine
combinations of concurrency latency etc
to increase your throughput not not
necessarily by Ness increasing the size
of each payload now what's interesting
about these three measures is how widely
they apply to a variety of different
performance scenarios so this same
measurement is applied to how you
measure disk operations so operations if
you hear of iOS when you're talking
about hard drives or spinning discs
versus as to see how many IAP scan a
disk do that's operations so this idea
of performance applies to very small
local measurements such as between the
CPU and subsystems on the same board but
we can also think of them as applying to
how data moves from the device all the
way to the application that's running on
the cloud so first let's start at the
lower layers here so fundamental to what
in my mind defines IOT is analog to
digital right the world is full of all
of this infinitely resolution analog
information and the first step in IOT is
often to digitize that into something we
can transmit on the wire now analog
signals are inherently an infinite
resolution both in time and in terms of
value so an X and y-axis they're
essentially infinite resolution and
obviously we don't have infinite
resolution in computation so the analog
to digital converter quantizes that data
and samples it to turn it into binary
data that we can send and different
analog to digital converters or ADCs
have different performance capabilities
the way you measure the performance is
in these two ways resolution and sample
rate so resolution is how many different
values can you apply to that Y access if
you have for example a 7-bit ADC you can
only get 127 values
potentially in your y axis and if it's
8-bit you have 256 so that's your
resolution and then the sampling rate is
how many times per second are you
sampling
these vertical lines how often you
sampling the value and while those
sampling rates are often going to be
very high and much higher than your
going to be sending or transmitting
telemetry to the cloud it's important to
know what the performance of that
sampling rate is if you're trying to
observe subtle physical phenomenon
that's happening at very fine resolution
either acoustic or vibrational something
subtle in there your analog signal that
you need to be able to capture and then
convert it into something you can send
to the cloud the other thing is to think
about time and clocks on a device so
clocks have one set of time which is the
relative time of how many cycles it's
run since it booted but you really need
generally some form of connection to the
real world time
you know today right now it's 12:40 for
how does your device know that it's
12:40 for and that's through the
real-time clock so these need to be set
either manually do a touch panel or
through some sort of protocol like
network time protocol
they're usually battery backed so that
if the device powers off and on again it
still has the current time it hat
doesn't have to be reset the quality of
these real-time clocks is measured as
drift and what's interesting if you've
ever seen air quality measurements in
parts-per-million
drift in real-time clocks is also
measured in parts per million so a
hundred parts per million drift in in a
measurement of how good is this clock
means that in a million seconds it will
drift 100 seconds and that's actually
eight seconds a day you can see how that
could kind of quickly build up so
actually most real-time clocks are far
more accurate than that and this matters
because time is used in a number of
places in your IOT solution first it's
used in the authentication so you're not
only checking say the validity of a TLS
certification when it might expire but
on IOT core we enforce that the the
timing of our authentication token drift
no more than ten minutes outside of our
servers time so 10 minutes should cover
most real time clock scenarios but if
you're outside of that we will recognize
that as a valid credential further you
want to have the
I'm set across multiple devices and your
servers all to as close to the same time
as you can if you're trying to correlate
events across multiple devices
if one claw if one device is set to one
time and another device is set to
another and you're trying to understand
how two events are related in time they
need to share a common time base and
finally if you're looking at monitoring
the performance of your system and
you're trying to measure latency say
from the transmit time of a device to
the cloud you need a shared time across
those to accurately measure latencies
and we're going to see that a bit later
so quick tip we offer a very highly
accurate free NTP service at Tom Google
com now real-time is a phrase we're
going to see this a couple times
real-time systems you may have heard of
and and one of the places is as it
relates to the kind of operating systems
so most of us are using a CPU and a
typical Linux like operating system
where application and system processes
all have access to the lower layers of
the hardware through a kernel and with a
kernel there are tasks that are running
that can be preempted and the kernel can
essentially arbitrate which process gets
access to the hardware and that
sometimes not always advantageous when
it comes to IOT with a microcontroller
the application can have a high priority
access directly to the peripherals and
where that matters is when you're
talking to hardware or sensors or
peripherals that have very strict
boundary timing on the say the durations
of certain pulses that need to be
consistent your application that's
communicating on that kind of protocol
needs direct access to the person to the
peripherals that essentially you know a
potentially microsecond level accuracy
so when you hear about our tosses a
real-time operating system that's
generally means that there's not a
kernel in the middle that could preempt
you from getting access to the
peripherals so that's a bunch of things
on on your devices but what are some
places at Google invest at these lower
layers of the actual physical
infrastructure that can affect your
performance and I've pulled out just
three of them one of them is our
investment in the long lengths of fiber
now
the speed of light is about the fastest
of way we know to transmit information I
actually happen to work as I sit
alongside our quantum computing group so
potentially they can do quantum
entanglement someday that could be
somehow instantaneous but we're not
there yet so speed of light is our best
bet
speed of light through glass fiber is a
little bit slower than speed of light
through air but it's still the best we
can do so we've we've invested heavily
and a lot of undersea fiber-optic cables
to make those long jumps as fast as
possible inside the data center we've
also invested in a whole bunch of
software-defined networking and a set of
cloths based topology and our switches
to make sure that we have the met the
most throughput between services within
our data center and then finally we have
been working on custom silicon to
accelerate machine learning both
training and inference and as you may
have heard just in this morning's
keynote we've launched edge TPU to bring
that kind of performance to machine
learning out on to the devices itself so
these are just three careers where we're
also investing in the actual physical
hardware to to increase performance so
now we have our sort of physical layers
and hardware layers a little bit covered
let's talk about how you package
information so when you're sending
messages you need to describe and
package a message and the first thing
you want to consider is how are you
going to serialize this are you going to
use JSON or something binary and the way
you encode a message can impact how much
time it takes on a device it also
impacts decoding it on the cloud said
but you might be more concerned about
the duration of time it takes on the
device how large the resulting messages
will affect how fast you can send it
over the wire but it's also going to
affect the cost of storing these
messages as they accumulate over time
and you need to consider whether these
messages are important to you more from
a latency point of view or more from a
throughput point of view all of these
can affect the decisions around how you
describe the messages the serialization
is going to decide also the format
whether or not you need to just have a
schema or description of your message on
either side so some formats are self
describing and more schema lists like
JSON others like protocol buffer
require that each the sender and the
receiver know in advance the structure
or the schema of the message message so
uber took quite a long look at this and
they compared across several different
serialization formats and binary and
compression formats and while you can't
read all of these essentially the y-axis
is how much time did it take to encode
and decode a different a given type and
the x-axis is what is the size of the
resulting payload and so the the
lower-left is sort of the best right
it's it took the least amount of time
and it resulted in the smallest message
and so you'll see things like protocol
buffers and Zi Lib compression and
thrift down here whereas JSON is way out
here right so while JSON is very
comfortable and familiar to us it's not
necessarily always the most efficient
way to send messages now moving up
there's going to be this is a very rapid
and high density talk hope you guys
appreciate that so as we go now we're
sending messages over some sort of a
transport layer there's a lot of these
different protocols of communication out
there and let's quickly review on the
right hand side are sort of layers one
through four of the OSI layering here
which is that the layer one is really I
think of it as that the the wires and
waves how things move as currents or
radio waves through the air there are
two is how you sort of frame them the
messages on that carrier sort of signal
and it's not until layers three and four
that we really get into Internet of
Things IP protocol however there's a lot
of information in IOT solutions that
spend some part of their journey as non
IP traffic and that might be over local
area connections or wider area
connections so locally we have a number
of mesh protocols right so the
performance of how many hops will that
message make on a mesh protocol will
affect your latency other protocols
which are more legacy or industrial are
bound by the the carrier signal so
Modbus or other rs45 type protocols
they're limited to how fast they can
transmit information by their their very
design on the long-range side you have
to consider
you're most concerned with throughput in
which case you might be looking more for
something like 5g or cost and low
bandwidth which you'd be looking at
something like n B IOT or cig fox or
Alaura so these are all essentially
different levers and and knobs you have
on the transport layer to consider the
other one is to think about the protocol
you're sending over these transports so
IOT core we offer both MQTT and HTTP but
there's going to be some differences and
one of the biggest ones is that MQTT is
a stateful protocol meaning you open a
connection and then you can use that
connection for multiple messages while
HTTP is more inherently stateless and
you need to setup and teardown a
connection for each message you send and
you can see that over time that overhead
of establishing connections only impact
performance but also power consumption
the other thing is that with mqtt since
it's stateful when you updated vices
configuration it can be pushed
essentially immediately down to a device
whereas with MQTT you have to pull and
see if you have any update config
waiting furthermore HTTP is a text-based
protocol you cannot send binary payloads
directly over HTTP you have to base64
encode them that inflates the size of
the payload that's you're gonna pay a
penalty on the wire for those extra
bytes of that base64 encoding inside the
message you also need to think about is
there a way to economize and batch
information in a single message so you
might say that you have many sensor
readings and they're all taken at
approximately the same time well you can
send one timestamp and multiple readings
in a single message and you're you have
reduced overhead of your actual payload
now you have to balance that benefit of
combining messages into one message with
the fact that if you need to process
them independently you may be paying
another sort of tax for that on the
cloud side because you're going to have
to unpack those messages so the degree
that you can gain efficiency in the
transmitting by by packing more
information into a single message versus
the unpacking on the cloud will be
something to consider but if you think
about all of the metadata about a
message that might be shared across
multiple messages that represents a set
of overhead that you can economize on by
by using a thicker message type
all right so very briefly I think how
many people realize that they're using
HTTP 2 every day so most people I don't
think recognize that there's been this
sort of radical transformation that's
happened in HTTP land over the last
several years this is largely led by
Google's efforts to really improve the
efficiency in way in the way web content
is delivered so used to be that you'd
open a web page the web page would load
a bunch of images and pull down a bunch
of CSS and each of those was another
HTTP connection it was very inefficient
so we looked at sort of redesigning the
way HTTP works now we open something
much more like a stream that we can
pipeline multiplex multiple pieces of
information over the same Channel we
deal with flow control so no head of
line blocking things like that and we
can push messages down and and this has
really improved the efficiency of the
web we've gone one step further and we
also have an open RPC protocol that
pushes our sort of API methods over HTTP
too and that's called G RPC there's a
whole bunch about G RPC I won't go into
but essentially it also allows you to
find services and clients and multiple
languages and this all rides over the
transport of HTTP to so IOT core today
delivers a lot of its telemetry
essentially all of its telemetry over
cloud pub/sub and cloud pub/sub has been
an early and avid supporter of G RPC as
a protocol however pub/sub isn't
something that is as simple as you might
think you'd sort of imagine oh yeah
publish a message in that subscribers or
simply gets the message and that's and
that's it but there's a lot of knobs and
decisions available to you about tuning
the performance of pub/sub and the first
is whether you do push or pull now push
you have this overhead I'll as I was
describing with connection of one
message
to an HDTV end point it's not
necessarily a very efficient way of
getting a lot of throughput out of
pub/sub we now support through G RBC
streaming or async pull in which you can
establish a connection from a client and
do streaming messages from pub/sub and
this allows you to attain much higher
throughput than you would be from even
batch pulling messages so this is
something you definitely want to look at
I think the takeaway with performance
and pub/sub is understand that if you
try a naive or simple measurement you
might need to do some tuning to get the
optimum throughput out of pub/sub and
one of those things is says well
parallel eyes consumption so you can do
streaming pull from a single thread but
then you can also have multiple threads
or multiple processes doing streaming
pull and all of that will increase
throughput the other type of way in
which parallelization can happen on
cloud is if you're using cloud functions
cloud functions themselves will scale
out each function can run concurrently
across many instances and finally you
can use parallelization in your data
processing so now we're moving up the
stack now into sort of data processing
data management so you can use
techniques such as MapReduce and Apache
beam and dataflow to process data in
parallel that will get you through your
data processing tasks much faster and in
fact in dataflow there's one particular
thing I want to kind of call out which
is pretty interesting that is if
anyone's worked with data processing
systems like MapReduce the first task is
that you divide a huge mountain of work
up into smaller chunks and then you you
divvy up all these chunks to all these
workers the truth is that that task of
divvying up work is not a very perfect
step in the process and some workers end
up with kind of a crummy ER batch of
work than other workers and they take
longer and so your actual job duration
is really limited by the slowest worker
of your set and you can see it on the
left-hand side with these long tooth
combs those represent workers that got
more work than others and so the job
does not complete until the last worker
is done
with a feature called dynamic work
rebalancing in data flow this is
actually dynamically reapportioned to
different workers mid jobs so that the
whole job completes faster and that's
not only going to be faster to sort of
result that's also less compute time you
pay for because you're not paying for
idle workers who have completed their
tasks early now let's talk about high
data rate whenever we're never talking
they're like like very high data rates
there's a whole bunch of things to
consider so first of all what is your
requirement around the integrity of your
data if you require very high
consistency and high integrity around
every message you will need things like
locks and transactions now a number of
database products and storage systems
will give you transactions but they all
come with some performance costs so if
you need that it's something you need to
consider into sort of your your
performance budget the other thing is
many storage project storage products
suffer from some degree of hot spotting
if he simply taught tried to write all
of your values in a very narrow key
space right so most distributed systems
use some form of distributed hash
to make sure that everything is spread
out across many back-end nodes and if
your keys tend to all land on the same
node that system will slow down and get
burden so if you're using things like
timestamps and your keys you need to
make sure there's enough randomness in
the in the preceding part of the key so
that you're not converging on one system
and we'll see a demo this in just a
moment the other is if you're willing to
trade off some degree of durability
there's really no beating the
performance of memory I mean nothing is
faster than RAM when it comes to
computation so if you're willing to to
expose yourself to some risk of loss and
some risk of a little bit reduced
durability you can support a much higher
rate of computation if you're only
keeping a value in memory and that
brings us to rate limiting so rate
limiting is something that's there to to
protect systems against overuse or over
our higher
Faust's it's something that you should
be considering and designing your
systems that you should be rate limiting
any consumers of your services to
protect the performance of your system
but you also need to consider how
capable is that system of handling rate
limiting and the back pressure you might
provide so if you're working with a
legacy system it might be more incumbent
upon you to simply scale as best you can
because that system may simply break if
you return a 429 like rate exceeded
right so if it can't handle it you might
need to deal that you also need to be
able to handle being rate limited
potentially or be aware of any rate
limits of systems that you're relying on
but there are some tricks around this so
I'm going to show a demo of this kind of
a quick solution and the idea is here
we're trying to write a counter value
into cloud fire store at a very high
rate now cloud fire store has a rate
limit per document of one write per
second per document right so if I'm
trying to update a counter in fire store
at a very high rate the most I can write
in the fire store for that value is once
per second so what I've been doing in
this solution is here is I'm using Redis
an in-memory counter and I'm updating
that in memory counter at very high
rates and then I'm using another rate
limiter attached to that and writing
into fire store once every couple
seconds so let's see if I can do a quick
demo of this so here we have a cloud
fire store and and a very simple layout
where we have one collection demo one
document called counter and one field
called count what I'm going to do is run
a little kind of load tester here and
what this is going to do is is hammer my
cloud function so you're just going to
see this cloud functions probably gone a
bit quiescent the counter will start up
a little slow but using a rate of 200
requests per second for 80 seconds I'm
going to hit this cloud function
I might refresh it so it did work
sometimes you've got to reload this
dashboard if it's lost so you're gonna
see these this value of the count go up
as a cloud function warms up you'll see
this increase every few seconds but
what's happening is Redis is maintaining
a high speed counter in memory and then
every couple seconds writing the current
count in the fire store so this is a
rate of increase that you could never
put directly into fire store you would
basically just if you tried to write
every increment of this counter in the
fire store you just start getting errors
from fire store because it's protecting
itself the rate limiting so this is the
kind of a technique you can use to
balance performance of different layers
of your system with some degree of
trade-off of throughput and rate and
durability all right
oh very quickly can kind of just walk
you through a little bit of what this
looks like we have a function counter
limit it establishes a a rate limit or
based on Redis actually I have a laser
pointer I can help you guys really
quickly here the rate limiter is
established I check the the I increment
Redis here no matter what I can
increment Redis because Redis basically
has close to infinite counts the ability
in this system at least and then here I
check whether my rate limiter has any
available capacity so rate limiting is
usually done in some form of where you
have a certain number of operations in a
window of time so I'm sort of setting a
rate limit of once every three seconds
here and then if I have available cop
capacity on my rate limit I will write
out to fire store write out the document
that's just the that's that's all the
code for what that demo essentially does
right there
so now we're up into the application
layer so a couple a couple points a
couple slides here on on the application
so the first thing you can do is when
you're dealing with different types of
data and say it's time series if you're
collecting data say from every 30
seconds but most of your users are
interested in something that's an
average of an hour you don't need to
compute that average for every user for
every view right you should be pre
computing certain information that you
know people are going to be working with
in the application there is a wide range
of caching techniques out there I'm not
going to go into them all but caching is
an important part around the performance
of your application if there's certain
data you know everybody is looking for
have that available in a cache somewhere
potentially even at the presentation
layer so I'm a big believer still in in
the power of web applications and web
applications are becoming more and more
capable in the browser in the client you
can do quite a bit in terms of pre
computing information in your local
application and then sending back to
cloud something every few moments if
somebody's dragging a slider for example
you don't need to send every every loop
of the browser you don't need to send a
value to the cloud you might do it only
once those sliders release that kind of
thing you can be proactive and this can
really improve the perceived performance
of an application so again in fire story
it has a system called fire store watch
that allows all of the clients all of
the applications that are interested in
a piece of information to watch for any
change when that value is changed in the
database it's immediately pushed out to
all the clients right so there's no need
to write a polling loop in your
application if that information is
pushed immediately firestore also has a
feature called latency compensation so
in complex applications you might have
one piece of information in the
application that affects many other
parts of the application and when you
change a value in the client in
firestore it actually returns the right
immediately to the rest of the
application optimistically right so this
is compensating for latency to the back
end it then has metadata that tells you
is this right actually have a pending
cloud right or is it completed and so
you can differentiate that in your app
but you don't have to build your app to
assume to wait for the long trip
round-trip for the to the response the
other thing is again remember when I
talked about the time frame being
spanning from nanoseconds to minutes
performance sometimes is about minutes
to hours to people right if you use push
notifications in an application you
bring to somebody's attention that there
should there's something happening they
should care about right and that can get
them back into the application within
minutes as opposed to at the end of the
day they think to check the status of
something so push notifications are
another way of of being proactive with
your users and then finally things that
I put in this category of suggested
responses are we all use everyday
applications that are very helpful in
Auto completing right if you go to the
same webpage every day and you start to
type that URL in Chrome it ranks it up
there right at the top it knows which is
most active and that saves many many
seconds of our interactions with
applications every day so think about
how to be proactive in suggesting
responses at the application layer and
finally offline all right so this is
something where you know obviously as a
cloud platform we're interested in the
application it tying greatly to
capabilities that we offer on the cloud
but we also recognize that applications
still need to function offline so if
we're thinking about things in a browser
we have things that we've really been
investing recently a Google called
progressive web applications it allows
web applications to use local storage
and web workers to maintain sort of a
fully functioning experience while that
while the machines offline firestore
also will sync data locally to the local
storage system of the browser offline so
the application can continue to function
I mentioned edge TP earlier the idea of
running inference on the edge means that
if you have a critical behavior in the
use of ml on advice on the edge that
behavior needs to persist and be
functional even if you've lost a
connection of
cloud so being able to do ml on the edge
and I would actually argue that be
mindful about having cloud in the loop
but in the in the application loop in
terms of the users experience the
canonical idea that you're gonna flip a
light switch and the light turns on it's
probably not a best place to put hard
dependency of having cloud in that loop
right have that loop happen locally
offline and then async keep that data
synchronized or report it to the cloud
but don't put a cloud path in a critical
performance path in a local application
experience so monitoring okay you cannot
improve the performance of something
you're not measuring and there's a lot
you can be measuring so you can be
measuring performance of the hardware
performance of the device you can be
measuring the performance of application
software either on the device or act the
presentation layer you can be measuring
performance of the network either
something we provide you on our part of
the network or something that you
measure yourself from the end-to-end
reality of your device to to a server so
you just it's it's very critical it's
almost nonsensical to talk about knowing
your performance or improving your
performance if you don't have
measurements that you can tell whether
you've made an improvement I'm gonna
show another brief demo so all right
switch the order up on myself here a
little bit when you're talking about
measurements of performance it's really
important to understand that some
measurements are a lot more useful and
valuable than others and one of them
that can be not so helpful is an average
right this is a this is a quick graph of
two distributions of data that have the
exact same average but obviously they're
very different if you were only
measuring an average for these two
datasets they would look identical to
your reporting system you would say oh
no we have a you know average of 100
it's great but clearly the distribution
of this data is very different so what
is common in monitoring system is to
look at percentiles or quantiles where
you're essentially looking at buckets of
info
across a distribution and you're caring
about potentially what are most of our
requests doing or what is our slowest
you know 10% of all of our requests so
if you see numbers like P 99 or P 95 or
how many nines of what your latency is
at 3 9 so those kind of things these are
all dealing with quantiles
and percentiles so back to the demo
oh no my battery has died so I have a
backup so I have a device it's been
publishing except it has tuckered out on
me so the backup here is I have a have a
screenshot
I mean also see if I can't get this to
come back online while I do this but
I'll go through the screenshot first so
what we have here in the screenshot is
the measurement of the the publish
acknowledgement latency over MQTT - IOT
core and so this is a measurement that
we can't provide you on the cloud side
this can only be observed from the
device side so if a if a device is is
sending a message over mqtt we do a
couple interesting things for you on the
performance side and the durability side
so what we do is when we take the
message from MQTT and write it to
pub/sub we will not acknowledge the
message on mqtt until after it's been
written to pub/sub alright so that when
you get an acknowledgement on the MQTT
protocol you actually know that data has
has already arrived safely and been
delivered into cloud pub/sub and cloud
pub/sub is a highly durable highly
reliable system but you might care about
like well how long did that take from
the device side when did when do I get
acknowledgment on the device side and
because the network is not a perfect
system not every message is going to
have identical latency and what you want
to know when you're looking at that the
quantiles here is you know what's what's
the average speed of my like best half
of all my messages so that would be your
0.5 here I'm gonna see if I'm lucky
enough the demo gods yeah so I'm
starting to get data now I'm gonna have
to switch my time resolution to the last
five minutes to get anything useful here
so you can see here that I can look at
that measurement and see as I hover over
each of these what the performance of
each of these measures is what each of
these buckets is and so you may see or
if you see a very high spread that may
or may not matter to you right but if
you have a user who's sort of reporting
or somehow you're trying to debug
something you're saying wow sometimes
something seems to take a long time is
it in my system well you may see
something like a 95th percent
it's lower and that might be fine
because you know that 95% of your
messages are getting through within some
faster rate than that but it's good to
know and if you were simply measuring
your average Layton sees you wouldn't
know you lose that information you'd
lose that insight into what is the range
or what is the distribution of
performance I'm seeing in these systems
you can do the same kind of thing not
only in this publish acknowledgement
speed on MQTT but at any other leg of
your system and you can in fact build
distributed traces of these kind of
things over the whole and the end span
so I've pulled up here also that there's
the idea of monitoring not only applies
to the sort of inward-looking
monitoring and measuring of information
around the performance of your system
but it can be externally facing through
the sensors themselves so the lower two
graphs here show the light level and if
I if I sort of pull out the device now
that it's restarted here it's got a
little light sensor it's got a little
display and you'll see that as it gets
into the stage lighting this should tick
up significantly and so sometimes the
same kind of monitoring you're gonna do
might be relevant for monitoring the
performance of your physical systems
right so we've been talking a lot about
monitoring the performance of the
devices or the infrastructure of the
cloud but if you're interested in like
the performance of say a garage door
he's a sort of trivial example here and
saying hey you know the garage door is
all of a sudden taking a lot longer to
open or a furnace is taking a lot longer
to warm up these are that now we're
talking about the performance of the
actual applications of IOT as opposed to
the performance of the infrastructure
and the technology supporting IOT but
the truth is it's time series data and
it's data that is operationally relevant
to you so the same tools can apply
relatively equally
so demo demo recovery there alright and
then just a quick comment about cost
right because performance can often be
improved if you throw a lot of money at
a problem if you're worried about
handling huge surges of information you
can simply have a lot of very expensive
standby capacity ready to process it if
you want to economize on costume a word
you just may let auto-scaling systems
sort of scale out and handle the load
one of the great things about pub/sub is
it has essentially instantaneous
elasticity on the publishing side it'll
act as that surge tank right so if you
all of a sudden want to publish a
hundred thousand messages you can do
that it might fill up a queue and you
may not want to have you know 20 servers
standing by expensively waiting to
process them all but you have at least
you've at least handled the ingestion
instantaneously so certain things align
with performance and cost certain things
are not so IOT core and pops up you're
really build on bites you are not build
to have a faster byte transmitted so
there really isn't a extra cost
association associated with more
performance for things like IOT core or
pub/sub other services like BigTable if
you want more throughput and more
performance you actually do pay more for
more throughput right so there is a
there is a correlation there between
cost and performance memory is an
expensive thing right if you want to
have the performance of Redis for that
high speed counter you need to
essentially have RAM on hand for those
kind of operations so in general you
need to be optimizing not only for
performance and cost and you should be
looking at how the impact of increasing
performance increases your cost or where
you get performance essentially for free
that's built into the to the pricing
model
so in conclusion I think you know be
mindful of where performance actually
has impact the phrase premature
optimization is is real right if you're
worried about 20 milliseconds somewhere
on on a publishing speed but you have a
transmit time of 800 milliseconds over a
satellite link is that your biggest
concern at the moment right should you
be really trying to shave 2 or 3
milliseconds or microseconds off of
something on the device if it's really
just a rounding error in your end-to-end
latency so consider each of these layers
right so just to review the physical
layer what is the if you if you look at
some boards for example I mentioned
temperature do you need to isolate the
temperature sensor away from the board
so that it's more responsive to changes
in temperature on the on the device you
need more compute or less compute can
you get away with an 8-bit
microprocessor or do you need something
like a CPU do you need edge TPU on the
device to do complex ml computation on
on the device or not is the
communication something you want to pay
for 5g right do you need the throughput
or do you just care about the latency if
you don't care about the latency can you
deal with something like envy IOT and
just send up you know hourly telemetry
and that's sufficient so don't don't go
and buy a very high throughput high
expensive connection if you don't
actually are not going to sort of take
advantage of it and then on the data
side recognize that you've got
everything from managed services like
pub/sub which will be highly performant
for you to sort of choices you need to
make if you're gonna run a VM you'll
need to do things like choose whether or
not to use SSD or spinning disk how much
RAM what instance type all of these
variables on the data processing side
can can impact your performance and then
on the presentation layer on the
application side remember that when
you're dealing with humans we can be
fooled right we can be that the
perception of performance is what
matters on the application side often
and so dealing with caching even if it's
not the freshest data or your users
going to be happier with
zip your experience or do they really
need the data from one second ago or can
you cash for five minutes and everyone's
just happier because the application
loads instead of waiting for a bunch of
back-end processes to recompute so
across the spectrum optimized for
performance one quick plug for those who
are still around tomorrow and wondering
what to do we have a project we've been
working on for DevOps so this is a
project from my team to sort of make a
fun game kind of a quest and a challenge
around doing DevOps live with a bunch of
people and competing in time and and
challenges so that's that's tomorrow
afternoon if anyone wants to do that
I'll be around for a couple minutes if
everyone if anyone has any questions I'm
happy to entertain them but thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]